hey youtubers is charlie so there's a
whole bunch of stuff happening with
Walking Dead this weekend we're going to
get our first trailer for season 5 and
we're going to go behind the scenes and
get a look at the set in addition to
that Scott Gimple recently talked a lot
about the differences that season five
is going to take from the comic as well
as the direction some of the characters
are going so this will be a breakdown of
all that including some really important
dates for when new footage is coming and
hello to any new people if you're just
finding me for the first time I'm going
to be doing weekly Walking Dead videos
tell season 5 gets here be sure to
subscribe to get everything I'm also
doing a special giveaway whenever Comic
Con gets here for walking data too much
other stuff so I'll keep you guys posted
on that so important stuff first season
five trailer this weekend AMC is doing a
marathon of everything from Season one
to season four at the end of that on
Sunday they're going to do a special
talking dead season 5 episode where
they'll show off the first footage from
season 5 like actual footage they also
visited the set so we'll see a bunch of
behind-the-scenes stuff I'm going to be
doing a full breakdown that i'll post
after that episode here so the new
footage is going to air sunday july six
at nine p.m. eastern time and then the
full trailer like the first mega big
trailer is going to air at comic-con
they usually save like the really really
big footage for comic-con but they're
going to post it online right after that
but because Marvel and DC comics are
hogging all of saturday with the vengers
and new TV shows I'm guessing that
walking dead is going to show that
trailer Friday of course i'll post a
full breakdown whatever that trailer
hits AMC isn't really nice about letting
other people use their footage but i'm
going to try and work out something
special behind the scenes so i'll keep
you guys posted on that too AMC is also
going to be screening two new Walking
Dead documentaries the first one is
called inside the walking dead that's
going to be on AMC july eighth at 10pm
eastern time and the second one's going
to be called walker to university and
that will be the week after on July
fifteenth also at ten p.m. eastern time
so there's a whole lot of new Walking
Dead video coming to get you pumped for
comic-con and season 5 for everyone
that's asking whenever it's coming back
season 4 premiere October 13th last year
so expect season 5 2 premiere within a
week of that typically they don't air
episodes into December so doing reverse
math I'd say season 5 episode 1 will
either be the first or second sunday in
October I know a lot of you commented
that you didn't think season four was
quite as good as season 3 just because
of all the craziness and Rick wasn't as
much fun and there just was way less
action but I think you're
really going to enjoy season 5 the good
thing is is that season five is a bit of
a reversal that every year they changes
the show a lot like every eight episodes
the show changes what it is season five
is going to be a whole lot of asking
especially the first half so here's a
breakdown of what Scott Gimple has been
saying about the actual episodes in
season five the episodes will be loosely
inspired by the comics and because the
Garrett villain is somewhat of an
amalgam of the Chris character the
leader of the hunters and because it's
largely implied by people bones right
here that the terminus people are
cannibals like the hunters I'm gonna go
ahead and suggest you reread volume 11
of the comic fear the hunters it's
basically issues 61 266 so if you have
read the comics just please use spoiler
tags whenever you're commenting about
stuff that happens in those issues the
episodes will be different they won't be
exactly what happens in the comics even
kirkman has told them the last couple of
years to quote unquote have fun with the
comic stories and norman reedus is huge
on the show Daryl Dixon is probably the
biggest character on the show next to
Andrew Lincoln and Daryl's not even in
the comics so anything he does
automatically has to be a change to the
original story personally I don't mind
stuff like that especially when they
change things it just makes it more fun
for people that have read the comics to
try and guess what they're going to
include in the future and just you know
pick out Easter eggs in the background
in terms of big stuff happening Gimple
said that there would be some similar
twist in the plot like last year we got
the virus twist then when the governor
came and everyone got split up I think
that just means that in the first couple
of episodes will meet the new terminus
characters as well as the non terminus
father Gabriel character played by Seth
Gilliam when I said that I just mean
that that character isn't going to show
up at terminus I think the first big
wrinkle on the plot at terminus will
probably be an official reveal of them
eating people like that will be the big
oh [ __ ] reveal even though the writing
was literally on the wall and littered
all over the ground Kimball and Kirkman
have been pretty clear about not wanting
to use a single big bag character like
they did last year like that was the big
twist of the mid-season finale the
governor this year I think it's going to
be the survivors escaping terminus it's
totally possible they could keep them
there all season but regardless of when
they escape I'm expecting season six to
turn into the journey to the Alexandria
safe zone they do have a few states to
cross terminus is down in Macon Georgia
and Alexandria is up in Washington DC
gimble also teased some possible future
crossovers with Robert Kirkman spin-off
show whenever he was asked
about crossover potential he said not to
expect it right away but it was totally
possible whenever the time came to
introduce a new faction like during
all-out war if you haven't read the
comics all-out war is like a big
storyline that takes place between
issues 115 and 126 remember how I said
we were around the hunters in terms of
story progression that starts at issue
61 so all-out war you know in issue 115
is way way off but I know a lot of you
asked me and yes I do think that the
show will eventually get to all the big
events and all the big characters
eventually even if they change them just
a little bit terminus for instance is
not in the comics and neither is the
villain Gareth the pseudo leader like I
said for all intents and purposes I'm
going to think of him as being like the
show's version of the leader of the
hunters chris i know AMC said they have
plans for 12 seasons of walking dead and
as crazy as that sounds you have to
remember that animated shows like family
guy and simpsons are way past that
number so they can wait a couple more
seasons before doing hilltop or a lot of
the negan story or all-out war and that
all out war story as big as it sounds
isn't even the end of the comic the next
story after that is called a new
beginning robert kirkman has been very
open about the fact that he's going to
keep making new Walking Dead comics
until people stop buying them which is
never essentially so as long as he keeps
writing new stories they'll always have
something to tell the spin-off is
supposed to be something a little bit
different it's not something from his
comics like not involving those
characters but it's inside that universe
so it'll include characters that we've
never seen before I'm hoping they teased
a little about it at comic-con but I'm
not expecting to see any teaser footage
until 2015 so let me know in the
comments are you planning on watching
the walking dead marathon at all this
weekend and do you have a favorite
season as I say I think my favorite is
still season 3 just because they kept
escalating things until that upgraded
ak-47 came out at the end so important
news I'm doing a couple special Walking
Dead videos on Sunday be sure to
subscribe to get those don't worry I'm
still doing Game of Thrones it's just
that there's a whole bunch of special
Walking Dead Season 5 stuff happening on
sunday and i know i promised a big
announcement so i will say that i gave
notice at my official job so i will be a
full-time creator very very soon it's
going to be a couple weeks before my
last day though so i totally just posted
a big video about all the new characters
we're going to see in season 5 you can
click here to get it and click here to
see my top 10 picks for negan thank you
so much for watching I'll see you guys
tonight I've
x